today's legend is Sinquefield cup
participant for the second time Veselin
Topalov and i'll admit when I've made a
mistake and in fact let's talk about
many of these mistakes I made the last
mistake I made was in 1986 and I
corrected that by becoming a vegetarian
and this is my second mistake which I
can now correct which is not being a fan
of Veselin Topalov
which changed last year at the Ziegfeld
Cup he's a great guy and he plays great
chess and I'm rooting for him topalov
unlike a lot of top players doesn't play
boring chess he doesn't have a lot of
draws and he plays for a win with white
and black and his games are very
interesting and topalov is a great
attacking player so I've chosen three of
his attacking games where he was
successful first game is against former
world champion Ruslan ponomaryov I guess
I should say feed a champion he's a
world champion like I'm a world champion
at hockey anyway so topalov was white in
this game this game was played in 2005
in his home country of Bulgaria and the
capital of Bulgaria is right and he's
playing the tournament in Sofia hometown
advantage okay and topalov plays d4 and
e4 but not at the same time and he's
playing ponomaryov from your favorite
country anyone where is Ruslan former
world champion pata Mario from Russia
was close close yeah the Ukraine very
good it's all about the Benjamins today
yeah fact when they had the world they
had the world championship but from
fidei which he won he played another
Ukrainian player in the final match and
that person was
the only other Ukrainian you've heard of
Yvonne truck right and ponomaryov one as
predicted okay so they played a Queen's
Indian which we've discussed endlessly
today right Queen's Indian okay
and he played g3 which is the oldest
move and maybe it's the most common now
Bishop a6 now between 1920 and 1975
everybody played Bishop to b7 and now
they all play Bishop to a6
notice how Bishop a6 attacks the pawn on
on c4 and white defends it White's also
tried Queen a4 but b3 is what what
they're playing now and Bishop b4 check
is the idea and what black is saying is
when white plays Bishop to d2 and we
retreat that this pawn structure doesn't
make a lot of sense normally you would
fee and Cattle the bishop if you played
b3 and blacks play a little more
actively Knight to c3 and black castles
in the opening is not too exciting
although there's a lot of notes that's
good okay and white black wants to play
d5 and play in the center he professes
it with c6 e 4 and d5 now in my opinion
which nobody shares that's why it's my
opinion certain players like to play
certain style I like to play as boring
as possible and wave from my opponents
of blunder their Queen that's my style
Topalov likes to play very aggressive
and attack his opponent and calculate
lots of variations ponomaryov plays more
like I do except he plays better he
doesn't do anything and then he tries to
really slowly I'll play you and so in my
opinion this may not have been the right
choice this variation because this is
very complicated White has a big Center
and the game is going to get very
tactical which black has to do because
otherwise White has a big center
nothing now you might say why is black
giving white a big center
well because whites king is in the
center and he still can't castle and
bike already castled so black is hoping
with the center opening up White's King
will be exposed on a1 and white is
hoping that since he has a big center
and black hasn't completed development
it's going to be good for Wyatt these
kinds of very complicated positions in
my opinion will favor Topalov because
that's the kind of positions Topalov
likes not not ponomaryov
if it was some boring position with a
lot of trading and the position was
equal then ponomaryov might be the
favorite not topple ups kind of position
okay so Topalov played a five very
aggressive move attacking the knight and
the night went to e4 and again black
black should play aggressively because
whites king is on e once we have to
punish him Bishop to d3 and this is a
very unusual thing I mean if I had had
white this game I would be upset that I
played g3 and I didn't play busy to g2
my bishop wants to go to g2 but black
was all you know playing d5 and
attacking my center and white decided he
wanted a bigger advantage so he pushed
all of his pawns in the center before he
castled in fene covered his bishop that
could be punished but it requires very
exact play and this is the kind of
position top lavas going to play better
than ponomaryov and it's a very good
position for us as spectators because
we're not going to see trade trade trade
trade draw we're going to see some
really nice attack okay he played Knight
c3 which the computer says is bad it
prefers getting rid of white's bishop
with nine takes d2 I mean I like the
ships I like this more than Knights so
I'm not going to disagree Knight takes
Knight rook takes and c5 and again
White's King is on e one blacks King is
castled
black wants to open the center because
White's King is stuck in the middle so
black plays c5 area
of white takes and black takes back and
they give a funny variation where black
sacrifices upon by playing d4 attacking
the rook and now if it was White's turn
to move white plays Bishop efore and
black is very unhappy or at least he
should be because his rook is trapped
so they give bishop to be seven takes
and whites a pawn ahead and I guess the
commentator is claiming this is a very
nice Bishop so black has compensation
for a pawn again if I can quote akaru
can I quote akaru there was a game
played in the u.s. championship this
year between Nakamura dacovian and a
Cobian sacrificed a pawn in a French
defense and the computer said it was
equal the position was equal and then
after like five or six moves of Cobian
was just losing and a cargo won and when
he did an interview he said yeah it's
equal but this is Ana Kobe ins kind of
position Akopian doesn't want to
sacrifice a pawn and then have
compensation a cobia wants to be a pawn
ahead and have compensation a cobia
wants everything he wants to be better
you have no chance so a Kobe and
sacrificing upon was an unusual event he
didn't get the right counter play and he
lost because he was down upon and I
think Ponte Mario is not going to do
this because as I said earlier Ponte
Mario that's he don't like this
Ponte Mar I would want to have white
here because White's upon ahead so even
though maybe the computer says it's okay
it's not ponomaryov style to sacrifice a
pawn for unclear compensation so he
didn't sacrifice a pawn he just took
back on c5 and Topalov played h4 because
he's topalov topalov wants to attack the
black king because because he sees the
black pieces over here and he sees
blacks King over here so his bishops are
pointing towards the King his H pawns
coming he now has the g5 Square for his
Bishop and his Knight and he's going to
attack
the black king when blacks pieces are
over here and I guess his king is going
to stay on e1 okay and now as you can
see whoever rode notes to this game I
mean I know who it was we don't want to
know who was they wrote all kinds of
variations and most of their variations
white is sacrificing his Bishop on h7
and so autumn re off played the move h6
to defend the g5 square let's go back
and look at one of the variations so you
guys are happy
rook to e8 so the king can escape that
doesn't seem like a lot of escaping this
ship takes h7 Knight g5 check now we
know why the pawns on h4 Queen h5 are
you scared yet if you're playing Topalov
you would be now whites threatening all
kinds of checkmates everywhere and again
these pieces are not defending Bishop
takes Knight pawn takes threatening
checkmate
I assume King f8 and well I would assume
g6 here okay they say g6 and rook f3
okay and my bishops coming here and my
rook is coming here and my queen is
coming here so I I like white look at
all those zeroes okay so instead of
getting checkmated ponomaryov preferred
not to get checkmated no wonder he was
the world champion and he played age six
so he's like you're not going to put
your knight here you're not going to put
your bishop here you're not going to
sacrifice your Bishop just leave me
alone already okay but he didn't realize
I would be lecturing on the legends
class showing topalov if he had maybe he
would have played differently and he
played Bishop to be one somebody in the
class tell me why white played bishop to
be one was he scared yes he's going to
play Queen c2 and that way he has
pressure on the cfl right Archer what's
the real reason because going to play
Queen h7 checkmate okay now the problem
is
when your pawn is on h7 like it is here
if your opponent plays Bishop be one
Queen c2 checkmate
you can play g6 then they're not going
to jump over your pawn and check me I
mean I would however after h6 now if
black ever plays g6 to block the mate
this pawn is going to be hanging so
that's unfortunate
okay so ponomaryov plays the move f5
which blocks the bishop on b1 we have a
call in voter okay and white took on
Poisson if white doesn't take on Poisson
I don't think this Queen c2 Queen h7
idea is going to happen because that
point I'll be on fi for ever so white
takes the pawn and now he's ready for
his checkmating attack black took with
the bishop Queen c2 there's no way
really to stop queen h7 although queen
h7 is in May the King can run away that
seems pretty safe right
no he played d4 and they give a
variation where he takes the rook let's
look at that this ship takes rook this
ship takes bishop now when the Queen
goes to h7 we have a double attack on g7
also that doesn't seem very good for
black so black plays d4 stopping the
bishop check check and then Knight takes
d4 and the idea is if you take my knight
I'll play Bishop b4 check and I guess
you'll go here and I'll play this check
and yeah looks like White's going to be
about 300 pawns ahead and check reading
black okay so instead of taking the rook
he kept his Bishop which is a good
defensive piece and play the move d4
attacking the rook again Knight to g5
threatening Queen h7 me he could have
played queen h7 right away but then the
King would run away so he plays Knight
g5 and the knight is taking away the
escape square
Black has two ways to take the night he
chose with the H pawn if he takes with
the Bishop then we play check and we
play Bishop takes Bishop and we play
rook f3 check again to show an audience
you want to show like a checkmate
but when grandmasters are playing they
they stop looking around here they're
like hey the guys check baiting me
taking all my pieces but we can continue
but the guy wouldn't even continue so if
King if King yet for example we could
play Bishop g6 check and we could play
Queen g7 check and then we're going to
take the rook and Black's going to cry a
lot again I've said it twice already
third time I can claim a draw when I say
it these pieces aren't doing a good job
defending blacks King okay
so black took with the pawn and that's
what I would do if somebody's
checkmating me I would like to take a
free piece that I'm least I'm a piece up
okay
and he takes now the rook is coming in
the queen is coming in very scary for
black pawn takes rook and you play
Bishop f4 now people who are watching
the game we're very excited because they
wanted white to play rook h8 check and
then Queen h7 checkmate that's pretty
good for white right checkmate is good
so why didn't topple off do that
the king would go to f7 which is also
good for Wyatt but topalov just saved
his bishop you play Bishop f4 and this
is a good square for the bishop because
when the black King is running away
there's much less running away because
the bishop on f4 is defending the
runaway squares okay
now White has a very funny idea this
idea with rook h8 check and queen h7
checkmate if it was White's turn here
white could play Queen g6 then the King
is not going to f7 and then I'll play
rook h8 and Queen h7 mate okay so black
I think started running away here yeah
he played king f7 because he's got to
run away from the white pieces Queen g6
check do you think he went to e7 or GA
what do you think yeah yeah gee I
wouldn't make any sense
because he's running back into checkmate
and then checkmate okay so you went to
e7 pawn takes check rook takes Queen
takes check well Black has two legal
moves that I see King here doesn't look
very good
unless you're white then it looks pretty
good and so I assume he played rook f7
or he resigned plane wreck f7 Bishop g5
check King d6 if you play King to d7
Queen takes rook check Plus attacking
your queen so King g6 queen takes rook
Queen takes bishop rip h7 white is
threatening Queen c7 checkmate
some would say black is a piece up here
I would say black as a piece down
because all these pieces on the
queenside are useless so basically white
has a queen of rook attacking a king and
there's nothing defending it
now what's blacks only chance here how
does he not lose it's got one chance
yeah
queen c8 moving in a funny line well
you're suggesting a move for black I'm
saying in the long run
blacks only chance at defense is by
checking this King forever if we check
the King forever we'll draw but you
can't check the King forever because
like I figured that out so he played
Queen e5 check if he plays Queen c1 then
he's out of checks he can't check with
the bishop because I just take it okay
so he played Queen e5 check and he
played king c6 and now his queen is
defending c7 his bishop is defending b7
and his knight is defending d7 that's
why he's the world champion I mean he
was the Fijian world champion
okay now unfortunately where the Queen
can't stay at e5 and white played Queen
e8 check the king went to b6 Queen went
to d8 Shaq what do you think black did
here where does King go yeah
King c6 okay now neither one of you has
heard of the term overworked you've
never heard that term before right
exactly in this case not only am i
overworked but the Queen on e5 is
overworked it's stopping Bishop Eve for
mate and Queen c7 mate don't you hate
what that happens also if you count how
many times the rook and the knight moved
and you count the same as I do the
answer is still zero right normally you
should move your pieces
normally okay so white played Bishop
efore check and most of you think black
has one legal move what's the second
legal move what's that
Queen d5 not not a good move okay
and so okay grandmasters usually don't
play to mate but we do in this class so
the only way out of checkmate
that's not Queen d5 is queen takes
bishop and now Queen c7 mate and we call
that a king hunt the King castled white
sacrificed and forced the other King out
now if you're playing somebody rated
1100 you may do that occasionally you
might check make their King on a king
hunt whoever you're playing ponomaryov
who is the world champion and considered
one of the most solid players in the
world it's hard to checkmate them and
also making them look silly in the
process you may think that these pieces
don't make a lot of sense here and the
reason you think that is your right so
not only did white win white really
crushed black again that's why topalov
our legend was also the world champion
although unlike ponomaryov he was a real
world champion okay all that also a fake
one okay so that was good now this is a
very strange opponent arc arc I denied
itch night itch played for Germany and
this term it took place in Germany in
fact it was in Dortmund and I used to
play for Dortmund and the Bundesliga not
to soccer Bundesliga the chest
Bundesliga and Natick about two weeks
ago changes Federation he did acara
wanna except he didn't change it to the
US now what most of you don't know is
that when there's a super duper grand
master tournament usually the organiser
invites somebody local so they invite
grandmasters from all over the world
then they say okay you can play to your
our club champion and then that guy gets
the beatdown right and this is what
happens in Dortmund
it's in Germany so they invite five or
six very good foreign players then they
invite one or two good German players
although the German players are pretty
good so usually they don't do too badly
so native lives in Germany and plays for
Germany although not anymore but he used
to and so when they had tournaments in
Germany they invited him and then he
would get crushed
but he got experience against the best
players in the world and he got better
at chess although this game he got
crushed
okay so topalov is white against Arkady
nade it she's a good player but he's not
one of the top ten in the world he's one
of the top ten in Germany
okay so Topalov like every other super
grandmaster nowadays plays everything on
move one just like you efore d4 you
don't hear okay he played Knight f3 and
c4 and we transpose to some kind of
Queen's Gambit noun a ditch I like him I
can't play like him but I like him he
plays a wild and crazy
he's the Steve Martin of chess okay the
difference is you've heard of nature you
haven't heard of Steve Martin that's the
difference okay now you haven't heard of
either one all right now a boring player
like ponomaryov would play Bishop e7
here okay and then he would read a book
the boring world of niels bohr while he
was playing chess okay Natick plays wild
and crazy Topalov plays wild and crazy
that's good for our class and natives
has beaten many good players for example
cramp up
for example magnus carlsen the last two
times he played him that's pretty good
again magnus carlsen doesn't like to
play wild and crazy he likes to bore you
to death okay thank his last two
opponents did die court case is pending
alright so natives played D takes c4
and Bishop b4 which is some kind of
Vienna ragas and I don't even know what
it is I guess it's the Vienna and okay
the knight is pinned so we're going to
take this pawn - now the problem is for
black black is upon ahead and black is
threatening a pawn but again
the development of the queen side
occasionally lakhs of these positions
although sometimes black is a pawn or
two ahead okay and topalov played Bishop
to g5 Bishop takes c4 s also move
pinning the night and then c5 the most
aggressive move and this is like the
mean one the Vienna variation it would
behoove you to know 20 moves of theory
and about seven variations to play this
that's why these guys are playing it
because they know all that okay now Y
can play e5 or Bishop takes c4 here
that's like the extent of my knowledge
and he played he five I think black
plays C takes d4 although I wouldn't bet
my life on it okay good okay now I give
up so I've seen this position but as you
can see both Knights are pinned and
attacked so if I was either color I
would resign okay because I this too
complicated for me and that's the kind
of positions the top 11 a ditch like
where they can prepare at home
calculated the board and they don't have
very many drawers now sometimes when
you're watching a movie
you sort of know what's going to happen
because somebody in the movie is really
famous so like George Clooney's not
going to get killed you know what I mean
so since this is a legends class and
it's on top love I'm going to bet on
white okay top love was black are they
bet on black okay and Topalov played
Knight takes d4 and now he's eliminated
the threat to his night but he's
attacking the other night
Bishop takes Knight and Queen a5 now
black has many threats Queen takes c3
check Queen takes e5 check and some of
you are probably scared of pawn takes
knight but then the Queen could take the
bishop on g5 now if you were like some
random I am who walked into the room and
didn't know this position you would be
like I don't know too complicated
probably both players are still in their
preparation and they know the position
hopefully okay when you play very
complicated variations where there's a
lot of checks and pieces hanging
and material is different normally you
have it already normally and it's
surprising how much these guys know
actually because for some reason their
professional chess players they study
chess all day and usually in complicated
variations like this the first 1015
moves if they can remember their
analysis that's good okay so white
played pawn takes Queen takes bishop and
again Naida isn't going to back away and
say oh no I ain't playing Topalov okay
what B if you do ask teacher this class
he would but he's playing for a win with
black against a higher rated player and
you may like white because as usual
black hasn't developed anything but you
might like black because black is upon
ahead okay and theory probably says it's
equal ok took on g7 and Queen g7 so
black has six pawns and white has five
although this pawn is pretty loose on
the other hand if you take it and this
pawn could be loose but probably the
overriding factor for the reason topalov
won the game is this Knights on d4 and
pretty strong and again and a lot of
games that topple off is winning he's
sacrificing material because his
opponent's pieces aren't very active
then the last game which somehow you
missed I don't know how terrible right
his opponent will had an extra piece but
they were all trapped on the Queen side
so okay so Queen to d2 this protects the
pawn on c3 so there's never going to be
any Queen takes here the Queen's on a
very nice diagonal and strangely white
my even Castle queenside because this
King's pretty safe over there there's no
black pieces that can attack him and I
would be I would think that their
preparations ending about now
okay castles Bishop takes c4 materials
equal a six does anybody think Queen's
g2 is a safe move that wins upon
yeah Queen g2 why didn't he take the
pawn
free pawn what's the problem okay
castles now you've taken a pawn that was
sort of blocking this file now most good
players like whoever this gentleman is
would prefer white because black is
getting in a lot of trouble on the G
file Black has his usual development
against our hero today and whites all
ready to go
White's pieces are all out white as the
G file white as an attack if I turn the
engine on it'll say some really big plus
for white something very scary you don't
want to take the G to pawn because
you're going to get in trouble over here
okay so natives played that move a six
and he wants to play b5 attacking the
bishop and put his bishop on a beautiful
diagonal he wants to and white castled
and he played d8 which the computer says
is bad and it says he should play b5 i
guess he changed his mind
then after b5 maybe black is okay but
again one of the reasons people lose
especially at the top level because the
top level there's a lot of draws but
when they do lose a lot of time it's
because there's a lack of development
okay and they're busy doing something
else like well I'm pinning the Knights
of the Queen I'm going to play e5 and
win the night my rook is better in the
center I'll develop my pieces later okay
so he plays Queen f4 I'm pinning his
Knight sort of walking into this fork
scary okay and again top who loves the
kind of player who likes to play native
a next reminds me of another matchup
which will totally confuse Greg and
that's good smart oven shear off there's
no question oh yeah I just said the
match up top 11 a ditch reminds me of
Kasparov sheer of you see why yeah he's
like no topple off in a ditch have the
same kind of style except top allows a
much stronger player much higher rated
much more successful so when they're
calculating and playing very calm
placated chess he can come out on top so
he allowed this fork with E 5 and black
instead played b5 which and of course
the person imitating the game recommends
e5 ok and now you'll notice that these
two were attacked and I was thinking but
don't believe what I'm thinking that
this should takes f7 is interesting and
the reason is if you take it which you
probably wouldn't I would play Queen
Shak attacking your ruck although black
doesn't have to take the bishop black
and play King h8
ok so instead the recommendation is
Queen h4 attacking the rook on d8 and
then when black saves his rook white
will save his knight and black just did
something very bad ok
this Bishop wasn't really crushing the
black King but after a 5 now that Bishop
is looking a lot better that's black
Kings looking very dangerous on g8 okay
so natives played b5 attacking the
bishop and white played Queen c7
attacking the rook would you take the
bishop and lose your rook No so he
played Queen f8 defending his rook
Bishop to d3 and so there's another
person who gives lectures here while
there's several the one I'm talking
about is yes or Sarah wine and yes er
has a name for this kind of position
which I think he invented he calls it a
free attack so sometimes you have an
attack and often at the very top level
when you have an attack you've given
something away like in the last game
Topalov sacrificed a piece he got an
attack and he won here white has an
attack and white didn't sacrifice
anything so it's a free attack but
that's okay he'll sacrifice all his
pieces later so don't worry ok so he
played rook to d7 let's look at one of
the crazy variations do you think white
wants to trade Queen
or black black wants to trade queens
that he will get made it so one of the
variations is Queen to d6 now it's very
difficult for white to avoid trading
Queens because the Queen has nowhere to
go
however why can't avoid trading Queens
by playing what sacrifice Bishop takes
h7 check and if King takes h7 Shack the
King moves it says a what gives a lot of
moves but we'll play King h8 rip d1 and
our plan is to play rugby 3 were caged 3
May or rip d3 rep g3 or move the knight
threatening maid and the Queen and just
like in the last game blacks pieces are
all here they're all on the Queen side
being terrible okay so natives didn't do
that he played rook to d7 kicking the
Queen out and play Bishop b7 developing
and and rook to e1 now this is the first
time in chess history there have been a
thousand arrows on the board and I
didn't put them there
whoever annotated the game put those
zeroes there Wow and it's rib Lee who's
very strong player now everybody knows
who Paul Morphy is right then you know
you know who he is okay
and when Paul Morphy played chess he
usually had an attack because he was
usually about 700 points stronger than
his opponent and he used all of his
pieces so this is a very more the--like
move the rook is on a1 and he moves it
to do the attack it tells you what he's
going to do and black played Queen g7
which rib Lee doesn't like Bishop to e4
and they give all kinds of crazy
variations I like this variation 'if
I've forking the knight in Queen this
ship takes bishop and if pawn takes
Queen rook e8 check wins the Queen and
then you win the rook in the corner and
you'll notice that White has an extra
bishop that didn't happen
because black saw that he would be down
a bishop okay so he played King h8
rookie three the rook wants to go to g3
but black out his King off of g8 pretty
quickly Bishop takes e4 Queen takes e4
attacking the rook in the corner
he played work to d5 and Knight takes c6
so white is better by just playing
natural moves but that's not top a lot
of style if Topalov sees a win he'll
sack apiece 96 attacking the Queen and
the rook Queen e6 okay I like the
annotator of the game is saying white
wants to play rook g3 if I was drawing
arrows I would draw the arrow Queen
takes rook but that's me so white wants
to play Queen takes rook that's a big
threat okay so the rook went to d7 rope
to g3 attacking the Queen and just like
in the last game these pieces haven't
moved if the Queen moves away from g8 we
have all kinds of checkmates everywhere
Queen f8 rook e1 another Morphy move
this is attacking this is attacking the
rook on f1 is not attacking let's play
rook e1 now black would like to play 96
and get his knight into the game but
your knight is hanging on c6 and you
can't move your dye anywhere else so
again even though white is down at Pease
he's not really down a piece because
these pieces aren't playing over here
and obviously blacks king is in a lot of
trouble rook a to a7 defense not a good
defense
and which one of you brilliant tactician
in the audience can find the final coup
d'etat I'm going to you to comments will
I get for that joke three two okay
yeah somebody said it very quietly Queen
f6 check I hate when that happens
unless I'm Wyatt then I really like it
okay so obviously I'm threatening the
King and I'm threatening the Queen so
probably black should play Queen takes
Queen and then you get checkmated again
good defense over here no not really
okay and somebody like ponomaryov if he
was doing a puzzle book and that was the
answer he would solve it in less than
one second and go to the next puzzle but
when somebody is attacking you and
attacking you and attacking you and you
have to watch out for every threat
it's easy to miss stuff so white was
threatening Queen f6 check here and
black either didn't see it or he'd
already given up in his head because
he's getting beaten so badly
that's a nice finish Queen f6
sacrificing your queen and if the guy
takes that you made him and these silly
world champions super grandmasters they
never let you make them they just resign
but let's pretend he took the Queen and
then he has to play Queen FA and then
mate also forking the King and Knight
very important okay so Topalov pretty
impressive let's see the last game and
this is my favorite of the three because
I can't flip the board
that's not why because he B Kramnik with
the black pieces and 20 moves just like
you would do and because of this game
there was a big meeting at the Chess
Club between the higher-ups and kramnik
was not invited this thing feel Cup
that's why right Danny
there you go but talk LA was invited now
I said this earlier in the lecture and
now I can prove some of what I said
in my opinion people have certain styles
and they're good in certain positions
kramnik is good at slow boring technical
positions he's the best Karpov was known
for this Botvinnik was known for this
Petrosian was known for this and Topalov
is good at sacrificing and checkmating
you well therefore kramnik by making the
game very boring with the white pieces
should have a good record against
Topalov but for whatever reason kramnik
played wild and crazy chess and did did
not do a good job that's not his forte
now kramnik as you all know is a d4
player he plays d4 he plays Knight f3 he
plays the Catalan he plays sort of slow
and boring and for some reason he played
efore this game now this game was played
in 2005
I wonder if kramnik has played efore
since this game and top left with the
Sicilian of course and kramnik played
just the main shock lines of the
Sicilian what's funny is Kramnik used to
play the Sicilian with black almost
every game and now he plays whatever the
most boring is an a6 which is called
what variation loud the night of' and
this is the most common variation at the
super Grandmaster level almost everybody
in the world over 2700 has had this
position with black and some times with
white - and Topalov I'm sure has had
white and black in this position just
not at the same time ok so already
kramnik is in trouble because it's a
position Topalov is going to play well
in no well and even if kramnik has
special preparation like homme playing
Topalov he won't expect
efore I'm going to look at this line he
plays and I'm going to have some new
idea once they're on their own it's the
kind of position Topalov likes the creme
Nick's not used to and to make matters
worse there was opposite side castling
terrible even though top lob didn't
castle amazing
so Bishop III these so-called English
attack v6 I think II five is probably
more popular now Knight g4 is popular ok
e6 and they play the sharpest line ever
now if this was shear off top along that
you could flip a coin because either
side could win but this is Kramnik
topalov and if there was a super
grandmaster who didn't know this game
and I told them Kramnik was white they
wouldn't believe me they would say creme
Dix not playing this position man are
they right I'll bet you cram dick forgot
about this game ok this is a very
complicated sharp difficult position in
topalov is always playing the knight off
with white and black and kramnik is
never playing either side of the night
wharf so you just don't do that and it's
a very complicated position where both
sides play for checkmate there's
sacrificing there's attacking the King
not good for Kramnik ok Queen d2 B for
attacking the knight and he plays Knight
bt7 sacrificing the be pawn and Kramnik
does not take it and then he changes his
mind and he takes it well normally an
opposite side castling black's not going
to Castle a queen side you don't want to
open files to your own King but cram mix
not used to this kind of position
Kramnik is used to a position where he
takes upon and then beats you up upon an
endgame and he's like I'm pulling up I
win ok and this is still theory but it's
just not good for for white ok Bishop to
d7 now black is going to attack the
queen black can attack the Queen this
way blacks putting pressure on the
knight also the Queen and Bishop are
lined up on the same diagonal so d5 is
going to attack the Queen so White's
gonna have to make a lot of Queen moves
to get his Queen out of there he can't
move his Queen away right away because
black just played Bishop to d7 attacking
the knight on a4 okay so Kramnik made
the
losing move I move 13 Knight to b3 if
you put this in an engine and I did it
says Knight to c3 and it says the
position is equal which means if two
supercomputers were playing maybe the
game went in a draw if two humans are
playing everybody would take black
because black has these open files to
White's King and white doesn't really
have an attack on blacks position 9 b3
is a terrible move because it unde
offends the F free pawn and Kramnik was
probably very interested in blocking the
B file but Knight b3 and the knight is
no longer in the center f3 is no longer
protected there's a lot of variations in
the Sicilian where black will lose the
tempo attacking the knight on d4 forcing
it to be 3 and here kramnik does it
voluntarily Kramnik doesn't play a lot
of Sicilians
so now cream mix idea is that he's
unblocking these two pieces his knight
on d4 was blocking his bishop in his
rook so if black ever plays d5 to attack
the Queen he could block with the bishop
or with either Knight that's what he was
thinking
ok Topalov played rook to b8 attacking
the Queen and Kramnik made a very ugly
move on the other hand his Queens
attacked and if he moves it away he's
going to lose his knight on on a4 so
where did Kramnik move his queen yeah
you said it quietly that was good yeah
well you like said what you were kidding
yeah he's like laughs he's laughing at
Kramnik I know yeah Queen Queen a3 the
best move was Bishop to b6 which pins
your own Bishop Kramnik is not going to
do that ok as he played Queen a3
yeah I'm sure Kramnik was regretting his
opening choice this has nothing to do
with any kramnik type of position
Queen's trapped F one's hanging knight
on the side and to open fire
- his Kenya however he's a pawn ahead
now Knight takes f3 now he's not upon
ahead and both of these pawns are
attacked h3 defending his Jeep on and
ninety-four now not only is white have a
bad position
he's down upon and white hit Black has
two Center pawns and white has zero
although he does have a queen on a three
that's bad yeah Bishop to e2
that's a funny variation the commentator
gave Bishop to g2 95 and night c4 wins
the Queen it's only funny if you have
black otherwise not funny okay so he
played Bishop to e2 95 well he stopped
Knight to c4 cuz there's a bishop there
but the commentator thought it was funny
that blacks Knights were in the center
and White's Knights were not and black
is up upon he played rook 81 Queen c7
Bishop d4 Knight c6 and d5 attacking the
Queen Knight c5 Queen to a 7 so this
Knight is attacked three times the Queen
on a3 is trapped black as a pawn ahead
and the commentator said the only move
is b4 and instead of playing b4 what did
Kramnik do he gave up some grandmasters
I'm actually not one of them they don't
give up early because when they lose if
they lose in 30 40 50 60 moves that
seems sort of normal if you lose in 10
15 20 moves that seems embarrassing
especially if your kramnik and you're
white but he resigned anyway if he had
played b4
the only move that Knight takes bishop
you take the knight on c3 with something
Knight takes b4 black is two pawns ahead
and threatening Knight a to check and
black has two bishops and black has open
files to White's King so instead of that
he resigned and then they're like why
are we inviting this guy to the sing
field cop don't invite him no that's not
way so that was what probably crammed
Knicks worst loss of his life with the
white pieces losing in 20 moves and
playing an opening that he's just not
suited for and I think since then either
never or very rarely as kramnik played
an open Sicilian with Wyatt it's not
something he plays so if he ever does
play it again he'll have four or five
games experience over the last thirty
years and his opponents will have 30
years experience you don't just start
playing open Sicilians at the end of
your career so that wasn't really a good
choice on his part but it was good for
our class because Topalov showed when he
has an initiative and he has an attack
and there's calculation and there's
attack for both sides he's a tough guy
and he'll be here next month planning
the Sinquefield Cup and he was here last
year playing in the Sinquefield Cup and
he had quite a good tournament I think
he came in third
I think so yeah so well good lucks have
Esalen in the singh field cup and well
is the careers not over yet but he's
still one of the lessons of chess I
believe he'll be the second oldest
player of the tournament after Vishy
Anand and well both have been world
champions and they've even played a
World Championship match against each
other so it'll be very interesting
tournament and well that was a great
legends class because topalov basically
in every game sacrificed material and
got it back with interest either with a
mating attack or winning all of his
material back so great games for Veselin
and we're going to see more great games
in the Sinquefield Cup which you guys
will see in about three weeks